okay so we're now in Italy we are all
happy to introduce Leo Stephanie media
was at some point visiting the UCSD
network so they work on a range of
topics from more applied a lot is
cryptography it means to algorithmic a
mathematical province in that descriptor
Gotti he's a science research fellow
here at the Institute and has a position
at the CWI Amsterdam where he's been
doing some great work on the mathematics
of love is an algebra and in this talk
will be telling us about the
quantitative analysis of algebraic
classes
Thank You Daniel so the official title
of the talk was classical and quantum
cryptanalysis I was too lazy to ask the
title to be changed but most of what I'm
going to talk about is actually just a
quantum kept analysis but I'm putting
quantum in parentheses because I'm
essentially not going to cover any
quantum stuff I'm gonna essentially use
them as black box for certain
subproblems I might mention them very
quickly so very much we're just going to
do cryptanalysts of algebraic lattices
and even more specifically ideal
lattices okay so why do we care we care
because we're doing lattice based
cryptography as we've seen yesterday and
the day before lattice
gives a great very strong foundation to
post quantum cryptography because we
have those the worst case to have
education connection those problems sis
and LEDs that are a very convenient to
build crypto system upon they can they
can be sure to be as hard as the worst
case instances of the approximate
SIV P problem so from from a security
perspective the question is how hard is
this approximate as Phi DT probe
and it all depends on what is the
approximation factor so in all the
algorithm I think we've seen pretty much
trouble source algorithm on Monday so
we've seen this llll algorithm from land
silence and lavas who ran in polynomial
time and gives you an exponential
approximation factor the story is quite
funny because I mean at the time where
another was invented computers were not
very powerful and when we were running L
ll it will always find something so
short that it felt that it was the
shortest vector it didn't felt like the
approximation factor was exponential so
the constant hinden in this ll is kind
of so small that you start seeing in
already quite large dimension but still
it is it is exponential and on the other
hand we have those perfect as VP
algorithm that run in exponential time
or even super exponential time and in
between we have those bkz algorithm
which is the basically making block wise
call to the exponential algorithm but in
smaller block size and that gives this
perfect trade-off from the exponential
time algorithm to the polynomial time
ones where we have up to the log factors
in the exponent the product of the
approximation factor and the running
time in the exponent is this product is
constant equal to one and the good news
is that the approximation factors that
are underlying cryptographic schemes the
polynomial or quasi polynomial so that
are in this region where the problem
seems to be very hard to all known
algorithms namely technical potential or
slightly very slightly sub exponential
time to solve so that's great that's
very secure the problem is that category
is not just about security it's a
trade-off between security and
efficiency and here we don't really have
efficiency because the key sides are
kind of huge with
besides that are quadratic in the
security parameter and in in practice
it's really hits you very badly because
n is in the in 2004 each you know matrix
entry you need like you know one or two
bytes so we're talking megabytes and
it's not the kind of size we want to
talk off when we do cryptography so to
escape this I mean this is I'm rewriting
history backward because maybe this is
not how it was invented but a solution
to this was to use this ring structure
where we replace arbitrary lattices by
lattices that we construct as modules of
number Hill for example so here it's not
exactly on the field it's it's a ring
that's not perfectly integral that later
came better rings but if we do this kind
of construction we get the same lattice
dimension but we reduced the key size to
linear or quasi linear this construction
was completely heuristic I mean
completely it was heuristic compared to
the things the more modern things that
we do with were sketch to ever
average-case connection but a violent
later came with this worst case to
average case foundation and they were
entitled the ring cysts and the ring
early problem or for short voice ideal
LD be problem and we have this the same
structure for category where we can show
that those problems are as hard as a
worst case problem but this time instead
of approximating the shop vector in an
arbitrary lattice you have to do this in
an ideal lattice this is applicable in
particular for those cyclotomic rings
that we really like because they're kind
of efficient geometries are also quite
nice I think geometrically they're they
have nice
and in those case we have this parameter
M that tells you well this ring is
generated by a primitive root of unity
and in that case you have that it's it's
rank or its degrees the earlier totient
of M so we might I might call em the two
conductor during the talk and and the
degree user the rank of the ring so the
question is that are those lattices as
hard as regular plain lattices general
dentists is and for a while you know
people were conjecturing that it was the
case until a long sequence of results
led to show that it was actually not the
case at least with respect to quantum
algorithms but it's not completely
devastating what happened is not the
whole line that got you know suddenly
completely destroyed what was found is
that after a certain approximation
factor kind of half way exponential of
square root of n suddenly for quantum
computers and ideal lattices in
cyclotomic ring the complexity suddenly
drops to polynomial so this is not so
devastating for cryptography for
cryptography for the following reason so
in practice no scheme was actually
broken and the reason is that here I'm
targeting this aprox ideal as VP problem
that is known to be at least as hard as
being elderly wrinkly or Linksys it
doesn't mean that it is equivalently
hard in fact there seems to be I mean
with the current knowledge as actually
this addiction seems to only be one way
and the other reason is that you know
even if it if it was the case that we
had the equivalent the approximation
factor that this algorithm targets are
too large at least some particularly to
threaten actual categoric schemes but
still it's a new cryptographic cat
analytic tool and it's going to open a
new door
especially explored by Alice more
recently and also kind of it really
shows that you know those ideal lettuces
are not just are not necessarily as hard
as Brady gives you a breakup and true
with extreme parameters no it's a
different attack the over stretch and
who think that's not it at all it's well
Daniel thinks they're equivalent there
is a reason that things break at the
same rate for now I don't don't think we
have any formal connection between those
two things
still okay so nothing got actually
broken by this attack but you know if
you can afford weaker assumption maybe
it's a good idea to do it and this is
what we did for example with the Khyber
so why such a gap the idea that we will
try to carry over to the Moors and the
details of the attack is to try to give
you a global point of view on what a
lettuces and what our ideal lettuces so
here are those pictures so there they're
not wheels that do not necessarily
correspond to actual lettuces or ideal
lettuces let's say that I'm talking
about full rank lettuces in dimension n
then one way to describe lettuce is to
give a basis of it so that's an
invertible matrix so that's an element
of GL n F R okay but there are several
bases that can represent the same
lattice okay
I can change the basis of the lattice by
applying a uni modular transformation so
that is a matrix that is in integer
coefficient and as in whose inverse also
has integer coefficients a matrix in GL
n of Z so if you want to see all the
lattice at once one way of saying that
is
say well the set of all the lettuce is
this coefficient GL EP 11 of r / g ln of
z so g ln of z is not a distinguished
subgroup of G 11 of our I don't know if
you remember all your non commutative
algebra I don't so I often make mistakes
but it means that in particular this
coefficient is not is not a group okay
this is just a space a homogeneous space
or immobilized space and this is because
you know we don't have commutativity and
we don't have another bad property of
this set when we think about it is it is
non-contact nevertheless this picture in
this picture what I want to carry
through is that maybe a lattice is the
left eye of my little fish and there are
many representative of that lattice and
those are all the left eye of all the
fish and the task of reducing a lattice
is to say well I kind of maybe reduce it
to one fundamental domain of this
coefficient or not necessarily a
fundamental domain because the reduction
algorithm that we apply they don't give
you unique representative but I kind of
like want to make sure that it lives in
a small region of that fundamental
domain but a covering set and the thing
with ideal lattices is that the
structure we can also think of ideal
that this is in the same way and their
structure is going to be much simpler
and the reason is that ideal lattices I
can multiply them I cannot multiply
lattices and this gives you a
commutative group commutative group I
still have to apply some of the duction
theory because there are several way of
representing the same ideal lattices but
coefficients in commutative group are
much simpler they look like just tiling
like this okay so in particular in some
sense the structure of ideal lattices
the whole set of ideal lattices hide
itself some kind of a lattice structure
right
yes sorry the change of basis is known
as a survey group element because you're
looking at the change of basis and basis
as a Z module you're looking at the
operation of changing the basis for
ideal that this is I'm being much less
sketchy I'm not I'm not telling you and
speaking of basis or I'm just this is
gonna get clearer what's where I'm going
at near the end of the talk the
operation of multiplication of ideals
yes I mean you did you don't need a
basis to define the product of two
ideals oh because Leo this must be a
very general question take it offline
but are you pushing ting by rotation as
well on the left no you can you can also
do it and actually you wanna reach the
reach the end of the talk I'm gonna give
you the two picture of ideal lettuces
and I'm going to coefficient by
quotation at least K linear isometries
yes you can you can consider but you
have to be careful when you define it
because I mean depending whether you or
left notation or column notation but you
need to caution by GL n of Z on the
right while you're crocheting by the
orthogonal group on the left so it's
even uglier and I don't know enough
commutative non commutative algebra to
make sense of it I just know it looks
funny
more specifically I mean I want it to be
a bit more precise about how general
lattices look like you know you might
have seen this picture's several times
so this is kind of a representation of
the action of GL 2 of Z or over a
lattice would be a point so this is a
fundamental domain this region so
lattice is you can view it as a point
inside this region but there is an
equivalent point in this region here so
you have like those translations and so
that's that's an easy action of the GL
energy but then more complicated stuff
happen when you start swapping vectors
essentially C is the translation vector
where you replace B 2 by B 2 plus plus B
1 but this does the swap operation looks
I'm not going to enter this but I just
wanted to justify that non commutative
things looks funny okay so let's go back
to commutative things and let me remind
you if you definition from algebraic
number theory
ideals
I even mean slightly more than this I
actually mean I'm going to compliment I
mean I'm not going to go into those kind
of details but I did for me an idea
lettuces is just an OK module in the
real complementation kr so you tend saw
your number filled with the wheels and
then you can consider okay modules in
that space
and that's that's basically just it just
make your ideal lettuces more continuous
otherwise you you know your objects are
rational our are described by rationals
and you don't have the nice continuity
that
so that gave you a number field and okay
it's ring of integers and I'm gonna
consider it so first let me define
integral agiels so that's a subset of
okay that is closed in the audition but
also by multiplication of elements of
okay
and fractional ideals are essentially
scaling of former and when now now when
I mean ideal I might essentially mean a
fractional ideal and among all those
ideals there is an important class of
ideals that are called the principal
ones and those are the ideals that I can
describe by giving out a single
generator so that means that the ideal
itself can be defined as just being all
the multiples in the in the ring of
integer of a single element so if you
think if you think of Z as being the
ring of integer we're talking about then
all ideas are principle but if you go to
bigger rings this is not necessarily the
case in some sense you do not
necessarily have
you kid algorithm over all ring when I
use ie K to denote the set of fractional
ideals and PK for the principal ones it
was already covered briefly yesterday
but to view idealist lattices I have to
give you also geometry because now by
this property we have that ideas are
closed under addition so that give them
the structure of Z module but for for
being a lattice you need to define a
geometry as well and you're going to do
this so embeddings so we have n
embeddings from our number field k to
the complex and we're basically just
going to align all those embeddings to
define the geometry so we're going to
view X as the vector of all its
embeddings and by doing that well we've
embedded basically K in the vector space
so we can view ideals as lettuces and
what is nice is that in this embedding
space the multiplication happened
component wise and it's going to help us
understand the geometry one last
definition I think it's the last the
algebraic norm so for an integral ideal
we are going to define its algebraic
norm as the size of its of the quotient
a coefficient in by okay no that's okay
KO scented by a move it's embarrassing
sorry about that I'm not going to use
parentheses because life is short and
this is supposed to be a measure of the
sparsity of Z idla so the bigger the
norm the less elements in particular you
can relate this to the volume of a when
you are the determinant I think people
it's determinant when they're serious
mathematician the determinant of a as a
lattice is essentially going to be
proportional to its norm
can you explain what is okay
oh sorry okay for what we are doing this
is alive but this is a convenient lie
let's say that I'm going to define my
number field K as being the rationals
adjoint viable and then I'm going to
cushion this by f of X so this is how
you typically construct then I'm going
to assume that this is a lie this is not
always the case but that's the ring of
it the ring of integer is essentially
going to be those same polynomials but
with integer coefficients some time it's
bigger
where was it so yes so the norm is is a
multiplicative map so I can extend it to
fractional ideal saying that for example
if I can write and ideal as a over B's
and the norm is just going to be the
norm of a and I'm also going to define
the norm for elements and this is done
by taking this time the product of all
the embeddings X is G yes and if you do
this then the you have a match between
the algebraic norm of an element and the
norm of the ideal it generates there is
one more definition so the class group
so as I said before we could we can
multiply ideals and this is in the
general setting this is defined like
this so to multiply two ideals I'm gonna
basically multiplies the element of each
ideals but this has to be an ideal has
to be closed under addition so what I do
is I basically take the closure under
addition of all those products but when
I get to principle ideals I I have the
properties that it remains principle and
a generator of the product of those two
ideals is essentially the product of the
two generator I started with so so by
those properties we have that the set of
our ideals form an abelian group under
multiplication and the neutral element
is the ring of integer itself which you
can view as a lattice and the set of
principle ideals is a subgroup of
so I can take the quotient of those two
group and this is what's going to give
the class group and maybe amusingly
one of the first properties that was
proved using lettuces and in the history
of mathematics is to prove that the
class book is actually a finite group
despite the fact that ideals themselves
are infinite and so I'm to write it with
right explicity reduction to the class
book I'm going to use the bracket
notation so basically an ideal is going
to be principal if its class is exactly
the class okay so that's a lot of finish
and hopefully you're familiar already
with most of this so what are we going
to do with all this we're going to solve
approximate ideal as VP and those are
all the steps that are necessary to do
this so first I don't like non principal
ideals principal ideals are really much
nicer so the first thing I'm going to do
is to make them principal or to
translate my problem to an ideal that is
principal and to do this I'm going to
try to solve we're called the closed
principal multiple problem so I'm given
an ideal a and it's not principal but
I'm going to try to find a sub ideal see
that is principal because if I find a
short vector in a sub ideal then I find
the kind of short vector in the original
ideal itself right of course you don't
want the sparsity of C to be much bigger
than this paucity of a otherwise you're
just not going to be able to find short
enough vectors so you need to control
that a little bit so to do so the
strategy is going to do as follow I'm
going to look at the inverse class of my
ideal a and I'm going to try to write it
to write this class using another set of
small primals so I'm going to try to
find a representative of the class
of the inverse of a and this is this is
a class group discrete logarithm problem
and those problems are typically
classically very hard but since few
years it is known that using quantum
algorithm that this is actually doable
in polynomial time so this is based on
the work of Eisen Hager algún Keita F
and some who have this generalization of
shor algorithm to continuous group this
was later applied for the class group
disk at orgasm problem by I'm basically
gonna let them explain this probably
next week at the quantum workshop and
I'm going to focus on the other steps
which are more related to lattices so
once we have this representative what
I'm going to do is to try to make this
representative smaller because there is
no guarantee of size given by the output
of those algorithms but by making them
smaller then I will be able to construct
my principle ideal see in the following
way and because the X are small and the
PI will be small the gap and sparsity
between a and C is going to be kind of
okay so I now have obtained an ideal C
that is principal and now I'm going to
tackle this and I'm gonna once again
apply some quantum magic so I have an
ideal that this principal so I know that
generator exists and in fact they exist
many possible generator for this ideal
and I'm gonna call my favorite quantum
algorithm and gonna get an arbitrary
generator of it again there is no
guarantee of size on this generator so
I'm going to apply mu multiplied this
element by elements from the unit groups
to make sure that this generator is
actually small and I'm going to output
this element this is a generator of C so
it's a particularly an element of C C is
a sub lattice of a so I obtained an
element of a enemy
I'm claiming at least that it is kind of
short yes and I'm going to cover those
things the other way around first
because I mean this this step was
discovered earlier but I think the ideas
are more natural this way so we're going
to start by this step well we're going
to start from a generator G and we're
going to try to make each other okay so
formal definition we have an ideal we
have the promise that it is principle
and in fact we are given this ideal by
one of the generator and what we want is
to find another of generator G that is
smaller so all the generators of same
ideals they must differ by unit right
because I'm able to multiple to am able
to construct G from H and H from G so it
means that the ratio is a unit so
basically the problem can be rewritten
this way I want to find a unit u such
that u times H is small and by small
here I really mean the smallness with
respect to the Euclidean norm that I've
defined through the embeddings and I'm
assuming that ideal is already given by
its generator but when you plug all this
in the big machinery for ideal as VP you
have to rely on the principal ideal
algorithm because by design song to
actually get this generate so I don't
like multiplication it looks scary so
I'm going to transform everything into
addition and I'm going to do this by the
logarithmic embedding so essentially
this looks like a multiplicative problem
and I'm just going to make it look
additive it's not going to change much
but at least we win we might
it's just more intuitive in some sense
so to define the logarithm of an
element's what I'm going to do is to
look at its embedding so remember that
embeddings are multiplicative if I
multiply two element then all the
embeddings get multiplied so if if I
want to define the logarithm of an
element I can simply take the logarithm
of each of its embedding and it's going
to send something multiplicative to
something additive one thing is that you
do not exactly need to do this for all
the embeddings because of those because
of those absolute values if you have two
embeddings that are complex conjugate of
each other they're just going to give
you the same information so it's kind of
its kind of useless so that's why we we
do this maybe weird construction where
we separate you know what what are
called the real embeddings from the
complex one so that means the one that
are kind of self conjugate to the one
that are pairs of conjugate and then we
send our elements of our field to this
real vector space are to 0 and we obtain
a good morphism from the field to two
this edited space but it's also so here
sorry instead of our should've written
ok ok itself is not a group ok if I
multiply integral elements I can do that
but I cannot divide them but it's still
a monoid and and the logarithm is is
going to preserve that to transfer
and the important idea behind all this
is to you know understand a bit better
the structure of the group of units and
this is more more precisely stated by
the earthly units theorem that tells you
that's two things it tells you that
first the log is the logarithm map is
kind of faithful it does not forget a
lot of information so more specifically
its kernel is just the cyclic roots of
unity of okay so there's just a finite
amount of them and typically you don't
care so much about them because if
something is smart and you multiply by
root of unity it's going to stay small
but the important part of the theorem is
the the second one is that the logarithm
of this multiplicative group is not just
an additive group is actually a lattice
so it's it's separated and it's you can
even get its rank its rank is going to
be L minus 1 why L minus 1 well let's
assume for example that all the
embeddings are real then if something is
a unit it sounded like norm must be 1
meaning that the product of all the
embeddings must be 1 ok so if I take the
logarithm I get that the sum of all the
embeddings is 0 so we have this
necessary equations on units so that's
why we have to lose at least one rank
but the Cuyuna theorem tells you this is
all you lose I'm going to use this
notation H later on as the hyperplane
containing so why have we done this well
because now this multiplicative problem
where we were trying to find a unit that
when we multiply it G by we get
something short we can kind of rephrase
it as an additive problem now we're
looking for the logarithm we're looking
for a unit whose
Logan example is the logarithm of H is
kind of short because I'm not going to
go into detail but the logo is in the
map also kind of preserve size of things
in some sense but in some sense I can
say that G is small if log of G is small
so now I'm looking for log of G as
something short in what is actually the
co set of a lattice and this is my
target so essentially we have rephrase
the problem as a close vector problem so
maybe it's weird because we started with
this problem I want to find something
short in the lattice and now I've done
all the transformation and back to a
lattice problem what's the point well
the point is that at the beginning my
lattice was arbitrary whereas here the
lattice I want to work with is fixed it
only depends on the number field and so
let me get a bit more picture all about
this so this is how the embeddings of
this number field looks like
so my ring of integer here is the
adjoint the square root of two and there
are two embeddings both of them are real
so it's nice because then I can plot it
in two dimensions without having a
complex two-dimensional board and I
recall you so my ring the square root of
two is the set of all the blue points in
this picture and we have not only
component wise addition between those
ring between those ring elements but we
also have component wise multiplications
you might notice that this plot has
symmetries one of the symmetries is just
in use by the fact that we have
multiplication by minus 1 that it's just
going to turn things around but the
other symmetry is induced by the fact
that this is not just any number field
this is
it's a Gallagher group it is sorry
it is a Gallic Sten ssin so in
particular is a conjugation that sends
squared of 2 to minus squared of 2 is
just going to swap the embeddings it's
going to send the x axis to the y axis
and the y axis to the x axis so we have
symmetry and then I want to bring your
attention to three kinds of elements the
blue one that I'm going to call the Auto
g''l elements so Y orthogonals will
remember that we have component wise
multiplication so if I multiply
something by an element that is on those
diagonals what it does is essentially
multiply each coordinate by the same
value or the negation of the same value
so it means that when I multiply by
those elements I'm just getting I'm just
getting a scaling and a rotation that I
don't get any distortion whereas if you
multiply by an element for example like
this it's going to you know increase
things a lot vertically and shrink them
horizontally another set of elements
Ettore you know central in here are the
units and the units are exactly those
elements of the ring so the blue dots
that falls on this hyperbola in red
remember that the units must have
algebraic norm one meaning that the
product of their embeddings is equal to
one and that exactly correspond to the
I'm also drawing those Izone on curves
so basically those are elements that
have the same algebraic norms lives on
this same color and why do I draw this
well because when I multiply something
by a unit I'm leaving the algebraic norm
in violence so it means that when I'm
looking for short generator you know
when I multiply an element G by a unit
I'm kind of stuck on one of those
hyperbolas and so now this is what it
looks like when we start taking stuff to
the
logarithmic embeddings and this is just
done by taking the logarithm of each
coordinate one at the time and it might
come as a surprise that suddenly all
those hyperbola it becomes nice straight
lines so now if so we have records that
we have a multiplicative mono read on
the left and basically if we take the
logarithmic embedding we get an additive
model meaning that here could multiply
point coordinate wise and this
corresponds to adding them in this space
but I'm not allowed to divide on the
left on the left Pickers meaning that
here I'm only allowed to add points are
not allowed to subtract them so that's
why we get this kind of a symmetry where
things there's a lot of things to the
right but not not much things to and
there is this particular sets of units
when I when I take when I take the
logarithm I obtain lattice so all the
blue points on the red line and you know
it is all terminal to the one one vector
because of this norm constrained the
embedding this one so the sum of the
logarithm is 1 now if I look at the
elements that live not on the red line
but on any or other of those orange line
what I see is that I always get shifted
finitely many finitely many shifted
copies of the lattice that lives on the
red line and this is just because of the
mono 8 property if I have a point on the
red line on the on the orange line I can
add the point that are on the red line
and that gives me a copy or lattice it
can it can happen that there there are
several copies or no copies at all on
each of those lines but it's important
with all this is that I can reduce using
my lattice I have essentially the points
on each of those copies of the lattice
they're representative of principle idea
they're correspond to one generator of
it and by multiplying by units I obtain
other generators I want to reduce and in
the additive setup this is very easy to
do this is something we're very familiar
with we just want to reduce modular
lattice all we need to do this is a good
basis of the classes so this is why
we're kind of taking those logarithms I
think those taking you know there's just
one or two basis of that lattice so and
because here we're in dimension 1 that's
kind of there's just one way of doing it
but basically it means that by
subtracting or adding the right number
of a limit of okay I can always bring
the point back in that strip okay and
that strip lives in logarithmic
embedding but what it means origin of
meaning is that I can always make sure
that my generators lives in this cone
and remember that we were stuck on those
eyes on on curves
so if I want to make something short
it's not I cannot make it arbitrarily
short I'm stuck on this line and
basically the best way of making it
short is kind of trying to make it as
close as possible as this blue line
right this is where my hyperbola is
getting the closest to the origin this
is a general strategy so now the
question is like can you implement the
strategy in general I mean you need you
need to know your lattice of Units to do
this and you need a good basis of it to
be able to do this efficient it turned
out that for the case of cyclotomic
number fields I'm specializing here that
this is this is actually very easy to do
because for for cyclotomic unit we know
a lot of Units very naturally they're
very easy to write in the general case
if I give you an arbitrary number field
computing units is not an easy problem
or at least if you don't have a quantum
computer but in the case of cyclotomic
sits you know they kind of pop out you
can write them by hand you don't even
need a computer and what is nice about
this is not only you don't need much
effort is that you can also study their
geometry and you can actually realize
that those units that are kind of
naturally given to you they actually
form a razor short basis of the
logarithmic lattice so basically they
all have lengths about square root of M
or square root of n
or Chanel so so the thing is that you
kind of want to obtain a clothes vector
but not for the l2 norm but more for the
infinity known because it's the kind of
norm that goes well through the logs the
logarithm is done component-wise so you
can kind of see why when you take
logarithm of exponential component-wise
you can have worked want to work with
infinity norm so you cannot just use the
algorithm we've seen for for the close
vector problem where you just take a
fundamental region given by a basis or
by the gram-schmidt basis this this is
not going to guarantee what you want but
if you if you randomized that algorithm
a little bit and try a few times after
while you're I mean after a polynomial
amount of trials you're actually going
to be able to solve the close vector
problem in the Infinity norm and you're
just going to lose a log factor
so that's kind of where the squared off
and in the exponent comes from because
I've done all this in the logarithmic
space so now I'm going to take the
exponential back and that's what's going
to lead to this exponential or
exponential of square root of N or quasi
square then optimation factor which is
which is basically because I'm reverting
the longer what's randomized about the
CVB
so what you can do is Gaussian sampling
and then you have you can do Gatien
something with a variance of square root
n and in the direction you're going to
have a variance of square root n and if
you're lucky enough no direction will be
greater than square times time log in
out of n directions
I knew you don't have to do as
complicated as Gaussian sampling you can
simplify the algorithm and make the
analysis more painful it's really you
want to solve it in the Infinity norm
but you're solving it in an ad l 2-norm
C's randomization till I hope to get
something that's better than the
elephant exactly yes yes essentially see
also vanilla tea some of these letters
just rounding the coordinates give a
good intuition on what happens on all
edges so rotated the autobahn of lattice
notation matters is the open yeah for
the Infinity norm the rotation comes a
lot so I guess I'm done with this part
more question before I move to the case
for the normal speed
sorry come again final term in the
length G you can't get a case where the
norm of the original generator is so bad
actually okay so remember that when
we're trying to find something short
it's always relative to the volume of
the lattice that we're talking about and
this algebraic norm that you have at the
end we remember that it is related to
the volume of the lattice so essentially
this these quantities that you see
before here is the approximation factor
whereas this one is kind of your target
so okay so so multiplicatively you've
lost this so far so good
okay so the second part the closed
principle multiple problem so now how
we've assumed all so far that's the idea
was given wise principle and now the
question is how do I generalize this to
non principal ideals and the idea is to
just you know make it principal or at
this fine sub ideal of it that is
principle you can rewrite this as follow
I'm given an ideal and an approximation
factor else this is not in the same
sense than before and what I have to do
is to find a small integral ideal be
such that you know this product has the
trivial class such as this product is
principal and I want the norm the
algebraic norm this time IV to be
smaller than this approximation factor
so now I want to find a sub ideal of an
of an ideal who's you know why that we
are not losing too much sparsity
and to do so well you're not going to
look for any ideal you kind of like need
to restrict kind of your search space so
you're gonna choose a factor basis so
you're gonna choose just a set of well
nothing's not even necessarily prime but
it's let's assume they're Prime's prime
ideal answer and I'm just going to try
to construct a B with the property that
I want which gonna have this form it's
going to be a product of over this this
set of prime and if we if the elements
of B are small and my exponents are
small then I can hope that be small as
well so before trying to find a short
solution let's try to just find one
solution and essentially that's a
discrete logarithm problem in this in
this class group I'm given a few
generators of my class group and I have
one particular clay place a minus one
that I want to represent and so this
kind of problem again was you know few
years back proof to admit quantum
polynomial time algorithm by yes and so
this is not exactly evidence stated in
the papers there's a much more general
statement but we can specialize it to
the class group this constructor is a
problem so that gives me a solution to
to this equation I want the product of a
times B to have the trivial class but
have two problems with this solution the
first one is that B might not be
integral you know if I have negative
coefficients in this exponent then I am
NOT going to get an integral lattice
here that's going to be somewhat easy to
solve at least in the case of cyclotomic
s-- the second problem is that the
algebraic norm of B is going to be
exponential in the l1 lengths of and
that may be huge
if I just use the old output of the best
song the algorithm actually what we want
to make everything fit nicely together
is an l1 norm of e that is why is the l1
norm well because when I take the
product of all those things I'm just
basically going to multiply all the
elements that means adding all the
exponents and I can upper bound the sum
of all the exponents by and I kind of
want all these elements to be all those
exponents to be positive anyway so
actually this l1 norm is exactly so one
way of thinking about this problem is to
think of the Cali Cali Cali graph of the
closed loop which
you can read still so I view my group i
constructed a kelly graph as I'm given a
group G and I choose a set of generators
a and I'm gonna draw arrows between
elements when multiplying by E by a
sense from G to G a so for example if I
take the additive group modulo 5 and I
take us to generators 1 and 2 this give
me this graph and kind of the question
that we're trying to solve here is that
we're given an arbitrary point in this
graph and we're trying to find a short
pass back to the origin ok the trivial
class we're trying to find something to
multiply by so that the product is the
trivial class we're trying to find a
short pass problem and good news is that
you know there is like if you take
enough ideals you know prime ideals in
your factor basis is that this graph is
kind of an expander there is like they
exist very short paths from anywhere to
anywhere the thing is that this graph is
the exponential size so it's not like
you're going to visit it's not like you
can easily find this path and once again
to solve this problem we're just going
to translate it as a lattice problem one
of the one of the way of viewing this
thing is to consider the kernel of this
of this map I didn't write the map so
basically I take an exponent e I'll make
an exponent vector e I'm taking the
class of the product of the pi/2 but
basically I'm considering all the
exponents and I'm looking when does the
exponent the vector of exponents send me
to the trivial class and that's that's
that's lattice right because the Z 2
Z to the B is is a negative group and
the class group is multiplicative so
basically what I have done is translate
my graph problem into a lattice problem
and I mean you can also view Zn as kind
of an infinite graph right I'm drawing
arrows for you know how instantly and
vertically that correspond to you know
adding the generator 1 and generator 2 N
and then if if if I look at the kernel
of this map I actually get lettuce and
it's kind of like there is a morphism
from this infinite graph here to the
finite graph here and the kernel of that
morphism is exactly the lattice of class
relations so if we rephrase this like
this I get it I get a class and this
class is the lattice is is a lattice
gossiped so that it so points modulo you
know one of those fundamental cell of
the lattice and
so basically yes one one target a class
is just one of those points and all I'm
trying to do is to find a short pass to
to a point of my lattice to a point that
is circled in red I mean this is exactly
a closed vector problem right because if
I find a closed point here then I I have
my pass it's it's a kind of a Manhattan
graph so saying things are closed so
that's it with pretty much rephrased or
problem as once again lattice problem
the question is that you know again in
general what is this lattice lambda and
this is in all general it's very how to
compute for an arbitrary number field
and even more so for an arbitrary basis
of an arbitrary factor basis so in some
sense the question is why should we know
anything special about the lattice
lambda that would allow to solve this
problem and again the magic happens in
the case of cyclotomic s-- we had this
beautiful theorem of statistical berger
that would take me to many slides to
formally give you but essentially for a
number for a cyclotomic number field
this lattice of class relation is very
well known very well understood we can
describe it completely explicitly and in
fact we can even explicitly give a short
basis of that letters it means that we
are going to be able to solve this
closed vector problem and it's going to
fall exactly within the approximation
factor that we are hoping for so putting
all this together we were able to solve
original problem principle no it's much
easier yes because yeah I guess on the
average the l2 l1 bound
is pretty tight no so here you don't
have to fight against this yeah you just
no yeah I've had hidden a lot of ugly
stuff to you so one of the difficulty is
that for applying stickleback or serum I
kind of want to take the pipe I'm ideal
and all its conjugate but it is not
necessarily the case that this generate
the whole class group so it might be
that you kind of cannot reach all the
elements of your class group in this way
it is okay we can actually live with
with needing several elements you know
just a constant or a small poly log a
number of element generating the class
group the other difficult part is
eliminating negative exponent because
you know if you have a negative exponent
that completely screw up your strategy
because then the ideal that you're
consulting is not integral meaning that
the product with your original ideal is
not going to be a sub ideal you need to
make sure that all the exponents are
positive one way you can do that is
because at least in the case of
cyclotomic or often in the case of
cyclotomic if you think the conjugates
the the complex conjugate of an ideal
then its class is exactly is the same as
the class of the inverse of the ideal so
you can basically transform negative
exponent into bars it's kind of
cyclotomic magic I'm not going to enter
into into those details
so okay yeah sure the more time whose be
pr0 for is the citation they kind of say
they relate this to crazy violence of
the Cohen Lindsay eristic so yeah just a
few words about the contents that have
hidden so far so it's based mostly on
the continuous version of the sidon
subgroup problem that was solved six
years ago by eisenhower hug and kiss -
song this originally was applied only to
the computation of the unit group with
some more work has been generalized by
Justin song to come to solve the
principal idea problem so that is
finding a generator of principle ideal
but also compute solve those classical
discrete logarithm and even more
generals I mean if you attract things
enough all those things are kind of the
same problem so and that that's the
formalism they use and more recently we
proposed the refined complexity analysis
of the continued students a good step
but they're still so because it is only
announced to be polynomial time in those
works and we you know for cryptographic
concern if there is a cricket analysis
that this polynomial time that is n to
the 25 that might not matter so much
especially on the quantum computer or at
least maybe not tomorrow so we wanted to
have a better idea of the fine
complexity of this algorithm
there's a lot to do and we did not
answer this question for all the steps
of the algorithm so we left a lot of
open questions you might be unable to
comprehend them without more information
and that's the purpose i want to
frustrate you so that you go read my
paper but wait for a few a few more days
because we're still updating it so it
will be only print very soon like so
many parameters the the thing is that
when you look at the definition of the
continued student subgroup or MZ there
are many parameters essentially if you
just look at just the dimension of the
ring so n this generic analysis tells
you at least n to the 7 ignoring other
parameters but there are many reason I
think it can be improved because like
the algorithm is completely generic and
there's like some of those question here
are pretty much you know if you
specialized things to cyclotomic how
much can you gain I think there is a lot
to gain you know it's like even you
before going to the non generic version
there are still some step of the
algorithm that are not analyzed in our
work in particular you need to construct
a quantum periodic Oracle from which
you're going to extract so hidden period
and that's what you do that's where
those others and do and we do not
analyze the construction of this Oracle
in your paper
we really just analyze the apparent
extraction
I think this this is this is a goldmine
of open problems and I think this is the
right workshop to crack them up 20 okay
so I want to mention you further works
and ongoing works in this line that and
it's not necessary cryptanalytic but it
it goes in the same framework so the
first one is some published last year
that what's a bit frustrating again I
you know I like big O's but I also don't
like them so I first use them and then I
say but what's the hidden constant and
in the Audion Alice's that we've given
you so far
I was hiding a lot of big O's meaning
that even if you know we could say that
okay asymptotically those attacks don't
really matter for cryptography because
the approximation factors are are just
too large the question is like yes but
in practice you know there's so much
hidden behind those big O's with what is
how can we explicit what's behind the
big O's and you know no for real wizards
or solve doesn't matter so much or not
for practice so we've we've done that
with flow so and and resolve scheme so
here for example in the blue line you
have the approximation factor of the
route approximation factor that is rich
by the naive implementation of those
algorithm and then we kind of like you
know because we were in those original
paper we were just interested in in
because we didn't do much effort to try
to improve what's behind amigos and so
we do that here and we're able to
improve the algorithms significantly and
this is the approximation factor we kind
of reach and then there's like those two
lines and those two lines are like
things that we don't know how to to do
in practice but we have an argument to
say that this is a lower bound of
what a certain class of algorithm within
this range could achieve I'm not going
to be more precise than that because of
course slower bond does not exist before
we prove P different from NP so it's a
very restricted class of algorithm I'm
talking here and then we compare this to
you know the usual algorithm that we
apply to try to break cryptographic
schemes so for example ll n or BK z with
larger block size so LLL is you know
it's Polly time it's something I run
every day on my computer well know if
the basis is too big because it is
probably time but it is very painful to
paralyze but let's pretend it's an easy
algorithm to run so you know even LLL it
would require you dimension four
thousand to beat
LLL with your quantum computer and
that's with the naive algorithm but with
with the improved one we've we've
decreased that to a thousand but
encrypted in catalytic context beating
LLL is not watching it you need to bit
much more powerful algorithm for example
if you want to break to break this
candidate they typically are secure up
to you know this set up to resist bkz
300 and the quantum other than even the
improved one is not beating BK 300
before dimension what is it
[Music]
8,000 or 12,000 something like this
yes this is the hotel meat factor yes so
that's why it's it's a straight line for
all those algorithms because basically
I've chosen the scale so that those
algorithm have a straight line and
because they have exponential
approximation factor but the constant
decreases as we increase B kg block size
whereas those one have a sip exponential
approximation
after the two steps of the algorithm as
some totally
some totally I think the asymptotically
the class group step cost more in
practice the unique group cost more so I
also wanted to mention this work of
hostel a and is established less yeah so
this time they like yeah cyclop Amex
it's just too easy what's happening in
the general cases but you know they're
gonna they're helping themselves they
assume that basically they can do an
arbitrary pre-computation that only
depends on the number field K so somehow
this is non-uniform algorithms for point
of view and then basically they
generalize the result to any number
field and they also are able to actually
obtain a full trade off and not this
brutal drop even improve at least in the
in the non uniform setting and you know
you see we I mean I'm not sure how
accurate this picture or how fair this
picture is that it means that the
algorithm might kind of hit crypto just
a little bit at least if you take like
the most the most extreme variant of
fully homomorphic encryption that have
very large approximation factors
I mean series of quasi-polynomial in
practice it might you know be in the
range where as others and actually
improve things but again that's only for
ideal as VP and not for the
being elderly problem that we actually
using crypto so you mean writes our
crazy is completely broken but because
this is parts of the CDP a paper I did
not cover so here I discussed the worst
case part in CD Pia where as to break
Craig's original scheme the the target
is is not worst case no because you use
sample so what happens is that you
sample the ideal the principle ideal you
sample it by sampling it generator so
the generator itself is a spherical
Gaussian but when you take this to the
logarithmic embedding you actually end
up in a small region of space and so
basically you end up with a BDD instance
in the logarithmic embedding and
actually the the really hard part in CDP
are you know that cause all those l
function and all that this is related to
this part of the result to the case that
you show that you can solve BDD
instances because when you want to solve
those BD the instances you have to look
at the dual basis and then you have
factors that pops out and suddenly L
functions are individual it's the
funniest part of the result but it's
kind of the one that lived the shortest
right you just broke that scheme
what it's like to give me the public key
and I find this you could be a little
better at breaking qualified to
polynomial time quantum poly time
reduction in a crypto people fair member
right which says you know if you break a
scheme you solve the worst case problem
now
no it's it does not apply to his scheme
right it does not allow you to ask in
don't it so that was a point that was
really the point we've read the paper
together yeah yeah because I I mean I'm
also gonna talk about a new worst case
to Irish Ches reduction but yeah okay
okay so now I want to introduce yes yeah
so it doesn't really impact potential
have a new image yes yes
okay so the thing is that what we've
done so far I mean if you look at the
two steps of the algorithm that I've
discussed I kind of really look the same
right it's like it's time we had to find
first of a presentative and then we did
some lattice production to reduce it you
know it's one time we took a continuous
logarithm and the other time we took you
know discrete logarithm in the class
group and I mean you can live with that
and say oh it just look the same or you
can say well if it looks the same
problem mathematician have a way of
speaking of both both things and this is
what arackliffe series for and I want to
use the ten minutes to introduce our
theory it's going to be a way to short
introduction
so
those two things are exact sequences
in an exact sequences you have that so
by each arrow I mean that have a
morphism and an exact sequence is is
when the image of each arrow is exactly
the kernel of the next arrow and those
you know those exact sequences with
exactly three elements and the trivial
groups there and down there I think
they're typically called short exact
sequences and one way to interpret that
short exact sequences is to well one way
to interpret this exact sequence is to
say well C is actually
isomorphic to be
it does not necessarily imply that B is
a Cartesian product of less than a times
not necessarily true
okay and okay so what have we done
in the first part so remember H was this
log log logarithmic embedding space and
using the logarithm map I was sending
all my units to what was a lattice and
so basically I can define T as the
quotient of the space age by the log by
the logarithmic I'm just going to call
it lambda there's a logarithmic units
and essentially what we've done that
step is to say um my my target is an is
a principal ideal and so I can view it
as an element in that torus and I'm
first going to try to find one
representative of it in H and then I'm
going to use the units to make this
representative shorter and in the second
part of the talk we've done exactly the
same thing we had one particular class
we used our quantum algorithm to find a
representative of the class being an
ideal and then we used relations in the
class group and relations in the class
book are just principal ideals to reduce
the representative of hopeless
and somehow what's tempting to do is to
try to construct an object that you know
lives between those two things somehow
we talk to important object that we were
dealing with where the class group and
the stories and we kind of like to
construct the the an object that kind of
combine both so it would be tempting to
say oh what what I want to work on is
times maybe the class groups the torus
times the classroom this is not what you
want to do somehow if this is what you
if the picture should look like this it
would mean that the class group step and
the torah' step would not interfere with
each other but this is not the case and
this is particle 'visible when you look
at the work of alice because she kind of
implicitly already does erika log theory
she construct one bigger lattice that
makes the relations and the units and
she does it by you know taking log of
okay first and by constructing the basis
that scanner that's looking like this
okay star and then she takes like class
relations here huh and for each of those
class relations there is a principal
ideal associated with it and she choose
a generator of the principal ideal and
she puts the generators here okay and
when you when you look at this this this
it means that somehow those generators
make the two object interfere in some
way and if we if we were to want to look
at this object it will mean that the
generators here would be zero then we
will have kind of diagonal structure
that would correspond to this direct
product so how do we actually construct
the right object well we're we're not
going to construct it directly we're
going to take a small ditch wall here
so the first thing I want to do is to
say that age so that was the logarithmic
space and that's space just look like
the some of the real over what I'm gonna
call the places or the prints more
precisely the infinite places of my ring
if you remember in all my embedding
there were pairs of complex embeddings
and real embeddings and i didn't wanted
pairs of complex embedding to be counted
twice those that corresponds to places
to it in infinite places so so this is
basically this is our to the to the l
except that I'm kind of giving a name to
each of those coordinates now
ideal lattices ideals sorry well so this
is a multiplicative structure and I kind
of want to a basis of this
multiplicative group
Rhymes by the prime ideal theorem right
any ideal can be written uniquely as a
product of primes so it means that this
multiplicative set of ideal I should be
writing it like this
so this is this is very large honor is
like infinitely many coordinates but I
only I'm only allowed integral integer
coefficient so that I'm gonna call the
finite places I mean I say I but of
course I'm talking about centuries of
mathematicians finite places and those
are in finite places and so all I want
to do is to first construct something
that just going to be all those places
so and I'm going to call this the
divisor of the number field K I do have
this structure and in particular for the
set of divisor we actually I think this
is this is this is simply a direct
product here so I have construct
something in the middle I those are
exact sequences but I don't want to
write the zeros to the left and the
right because I don't have enough whom
to do that and yeah now I'm going to try
to complete this this whole commutative
diagram so on the top what's what's
happening so we have the unit's here I
mean we have to forget the roots of
unity because they're always annoying
and we have principal ideals here and if
we remember you know a principal ideal
you can view it as an element of the
field modular units right because if you
change a unit that generates still the
same principle ideal so what you can do
is to write another arrow here and here
you're gonna have filled the field
itself k star I'm removing 0 because
is zero a real ideal or not that's a
difficult question I'm gonna assume it's
not okay
[Music]
and so yeah maybe I should have given
the different formal definition of Deeb
okay I mean this is just a direct sum
that we have here okay so a divisor the
visa is just an element of this this big
group here this is over the places the
finite places so I mean the division is
just like a stupid formal son of stud
right and I'm going to be able to
construct an arrow like this by sending
an element alpha to what we write like
this with strange parentheses and this
is going to be I kind of need to
evaluate alpha at all the places
so on infinite places we know how to
evaluate alpha we just you know take its
its log embeddings so just going to be
the same for all the infinite places of
U of alpha and I'm gonna take absolute
values and log around that so that the
multiplicative structure is sent to
additive and the other thing I'm going
to do is I'm gonna write the ideal
generated by alpha so okay can you see
down there I'm gonna write it as a
product of prime ideals I and that's
going to give me the finite part it's
the sum over all the prime ideals of
to add a special symbol new here this is
a formalism so I need a special symbol
for each of my basis elements I
that that gives me an hour from here to
here
so now I have and now from here to here
so what can I do well I can define a
quotient and this quotient is called a
peekaboo and then I'm thankful for
country teaching me about this magic
lemma called the 9 lemma that tells you
that when you have these pictures
actually those arrow exist and the
diagram commutes and all sequences are
exact and I'm not gonna prove it so why
do we care
well first it looks nice
the pker group we've we've had this
exact sequence where on the Left we had
the tourists and on the right we had a
finite group so it means that kind of
the pker group looks like a bunch of
donuts okay
this bunch of donuts does mean something
to the peak our group actually should do
some more work you can realize that it
is corresponds to the set of ideal
lettuces modulo scaling isometric so
this is really an object we want to look
at right we are looking at all the ideal
lettuces from a global point of view
each point in this group correspond to
an ideal lettuces I think that if we
want to understand how ideals relate to
each other we want to view them in them
group this is what we are currently
doing with school and Alice and Benjamin
the main theorem that we're proving is
that if you do a short random walk in
the speaker group I'm not going to
define what it means you're very quickly
after after just a few steps you become
uniform inside the pker group okay like
this it doesn't sound may be so
important actually you can deduce a lot
of application out of this theorem
the first one is that you have run
themself reducibility of the ideal SVP
problem essentially this random walk is
going to allow me to send the problem
over any ideal to a Honda my deal in the
picker group so that's that's a
worst-case Travis cash reduction it
doesn't look at all like the one that we
have had so far but well it's funny is
that it looks very much like the self
reduce ability that we know for discrete
location over elliptic curve the result
of Benjamin let's say that you can Han
demise an elliptic curve inside the nice
agenda class and this is exactly the
same strategy but do we have other
applications we can eliminate some of
the heuristics of the previous result of
Alice and we can eliminate your wrists
so those you can this one you can
understand as the the heuristic once you
use you speak in the language of the
picker groups you can understand our
heuristic is basically saying that the
head use of the peak our group is not so
large and because we just say that a
random walk takes you uniformly it means
that over a short walks takes you
anywhere so this Hajus is kind of small
and then we are able to eliminate
heuristics maybe in other context which
might seems a bit stranger why would
that relate if you're interested we can
discuss it offline but basically these
theorems can help you to prove that when
you sample an element in an ideal then
the the relative norm of your lemon to
your ideal is maybe easy to factor you
know it's smooth or near prime or
something so we can do this at least for
the for some algorithm that twin has
been working on for a while we're also
hoping maybe later that we can apply the
strategies to
being the subjects financial algorithm
gjp problem offer unique I think I'm
when you lose something in the
approximation no no no I'm losing
something and this deep and losing an
approximation factor that's going to
depend on the lengths of my walk so
that's why I want fast on the musician
we are still analyzing that I mean for
sure his his reduction is requires a
factoring occur so we do I mean our
reduction is classical and his eyes are
quantum or her super her polynomial the
exact numbers I don't know I mean it
also differs in the sense of the
distribution of what we mean by random
ideal is distribution as say is it's
only considering integral ideals and is
taking a condom integral a yield with in
it's not even uniform but it's like
inversely proportional to its Norman and
interval of norms we're doing uniform in
picado maybe to cryptographers it
doesn't matter at all
I think mathematically it is much more
meaningful because because of these
properties at the peak our group is is
exactly exactly that's what I mentioned
that I'm hoping that this kind of
techniques will help you eliminate some
of the heuristic of the algorithm that
you've been working on a lot which
heuristic the heuristic that when you
take an element in an ideal then the
relative norm of that element to the
original ideal that it kind of behaved
randomly because you want this you know
you want you want this relative norm you
want it to have a relatively smooth norm
for example you want it to be easy to
factor so will be the probability of
finding a smooth element yes but that
doesn't tell you that the relation you
sample in the lattice of relations your
classwork is random
no no I'm not saying we can eliminate
all the heuristic yeah I'm just I'm just
saying we are having a a new handle
that's why you know there's a question
mark it's it's big open problem I you
could hit the same relations over and
over with a very very well unwise
poverty like if you if you get that
probably of getting smooth elements you
could you you would not necessarily know
if you're hitting new relations uh so I
mean it's not like we just you know
apply the usual algorithm and do this
it's more like okay we're gonna make the
algorithm look uglier we're gonna do
things that are not necessarily natural
in a yearís t'k sense but we're gonna
make it fit the theorems so I'm not
saying I'm taking your theorem black box
and apply my magic and and we're done
it's like it's more like we have handles
and we can modify a liturgy algorithms
and tweak things not necessarily fully
provable that may be more provable if
you want any right between the table
that we keep talking over there another
announcement so tomorrow's schedule
right not it on the website it is the
wrong times tomorrow schedule is going
to be just like today starting at 9:30
with two tops in the morning maybe
website has been fixed okay
and the ratio